Привіт, мене звати Віктор Мельников.
Я викладач математики в школі “Майбутні”.
Сьогодні у нас заняття для 9 класу
за темою “Сума та різниця векторів”.
Раніше ми вивчали, що таке “вектор” -
вектор - це направлений відрізок, початок
якого записується на першому місці.
Якщо у нас вектор АВ,
то А - початок, В - кінець.
Також у вектора є координати.
Щоб знайти координати вектора,
треба від координати кінця
відняти координати початку.
Також ми вивчили поняття “модуль вектора”.
Модуль вектора - це корінь із
суми квадратів його координат.
Модуль вектора це те
саме, що і довжина відрізка,
з якого складається вектор.
Вектори використовуються багато де,
сьогодні у нас будуть приклади із
програмування і комп’ютерних ігор.
Наприклад
Ми можемо використати вектор
для того, щоб зберегти в якому напрямку
хтось дивиться або куди
рухається. Або просто подивіться
ось, наприклад, пістолет рухається
в напрямку (1;0), просто
дивиться вправо, тобто завдання напрямку.
Ми можемо використати вектор
для того, щоб подивитися
крім напрямку, в якому рухається об’єкт,
ще й швидкість, з якою він рухається.
Чим більше швидкість, тим більша
довжина вектора.
А напрям вектора показує,
куди рухається об’єкт.
Це другий спосіб, і третій -
для зберігання розміщення.
Наприклад, що ця людина знаходиться
за координатою, якому
відповідає вектор (5;1).
Сьогодні будемо вивчати як додавати
та віднімати вектори
і розв’язувати задачі, щоб
практикуватися в цих навичках.
Людина пішла в один замок,
а потім — в інший.
Загальне переміщення
позначено червоним вектором,
із першого одразу в останній
це називається сумою векторів.
Для того, щоб додати вектори,
треба сумістити початок
другого вектора і кінець першого.
І вектор, який починається з
початку першого в кінець другого,
це і буде сумою двох векторів.
Це правило трикутника.
Алгоритм правила трикутника:
У нас є два вектори.
Для того, щоб їх додати,
потрібно один з них
паралельно перенести так
щоб
кінець одного співпадав з початком іншого.
Наприклад, вектор b перенести сюди
паралельно намалювати. Це буде вектор b
Сумою цих двух векторів
називатиметься вектор, який починається
з початку першого і йде в кінець другого.
Так само можна паралельно
перенести вектор а
так, щоб співпадав його
початок з кінцем вектора b.
Це вектор a
Знайдемо їх суму.
Переносимо вектор b так, щоб його початок
співпадав з кінцем вектора а.
Сума векторів - це
вектор, який починається
з початку вектора а і закінчується на
кінці вектора b. Це правило трикутника.
Давайте попрактикуємось в задачах
Потрібно знайти суму намальованих векторів
Розглянемо на першому
малюнку вектори a і b.
Вектор а: п'ять клітинок вправо, дві вверх
Треба до нього додати вектор b
Вектор b переносимо так щоб його початок
співпадав з кінцем вектора а.
Малюємо вектор b на три вниз, три вправо
І тоді загальна сума
це вектор, який виходить
з початку вектора а
і закінчується на кінці
вектора b. Це зрозуміло.
А що буде, коли вектори
лежать на паралельних
прямих?
Наприклад, це варіант Г.
де вектор а і вектор b лежать на
паралельних прямих, тобто колінеарно.
Насправді нічого важкого.
Малюємо вектор а
і вектор b, переносимо так,
щоб його початок
співпадав з кінцем вектора а.
Якщо вони були паралельні, просто
продовжиться ця лінія.
Тоді, щоб намалювати
суму цих двох векторів,
нам треба спочатку першого
аж в кінець прорухати.
Цей червоний вектор, який
співпадає з довжинами векторів a і b
є сумою цих векторів a+b.
Якщо вони направлені в зворотному напрямку -
колінеарні, але протилежного напрямку.
Все те саме. Це варіант д).
Вектор b малюємо так, щоб його початок
співпадав з кінцем вектора а.
Так вони співпадають, налягають
І тоді сума векторів
є вектор, який починається з початку
першого до кінця другого.
І в цьому напрямку буде їх сума.
а+b
Якщо вектори протилежні,
і вони однакові, але
протележно направлені.
То їх сума буде нуль.
Давайте попрактикуємося
в наступній задачі.
Треба накреслити паралелограм АВСD
і побудувати вектори, суми яких написані.
Паралелограм АВСD.
Знайти суму векторів BC+BA.
Для того, щоб знайти цю суму за правилом
трикутника, переносимо вектор BA так,
щоб його початок збігався
з кінцем вектора BC.
Беремо і переносимо
Це буде вектор BD, це
є сума даних векторів.
Спробуємо BC + DC.
BC + DC.
Нам треба перенести вектор так, щоб
початок одного співпадав з кінцем іншого.
Або ВС перенести ось сюди,
або DC перенести ось сюди.
Скористаємось другим варіантом.
Вектор DC (червоний колір) це те саме,
що і вектор АВ.
Тоді вектор АВ + вектор ВС,
починаємо спочатку і куди прийшли.
Тоді вектор AC буде сумою даних векторів.
Всі інші приклади робляться так само.
Якщо ми додаємо вектори, то що
відбувається з їхніми координатами,
вони також додаються.
Тобто якщо у нас вектор
а з координатами (1;2)
і якийсь вектор b з координатами (2;-1)
то якщо ми додаємо вектор
то отримаємо новий вектор у якого
координати будуть сумою а і b.
Тобто (3;1)
Чому так можна робити? Уявімо три точки
АВС
це вектор А і вектор В
Координати А (х1,у1),
В( х2,у2)
і С (х3,у3).
Знайти координати векторів а і b.
Вектор а має координати х2-х1
і так само з ігреками.
Те саме робимо з вектором b
тільки від координат с віднімаємо b
x3-x2
y3-y2
Це координати вектора а
Це координати вектора b
Тепер знайдемо координати їх суми.
Якщо ми додаємо вектори АВ і ВС,
то вийде вектор АС.
AC - це сума а + b
Які координати матиме їх сума?
Треба від координат третьої точки (х3;y3)
відняти координати першої (х1;y1)
Це буде: х3-х1; y3-y1
Що буде, якщо ми додамо ці координати?
х2-х1+х3-х2
Залишиться х3-х1.
Вийде те саме, що координати вектора АС,
тобто їхньої суми.
Так само можна перевірити, що у також
задовольнятимуть сумі співвідношень.
Це означає, що якщо у нас є два вектори,
то щоб знайти координати суми,
треба просто попарно
додати координати по х та у.
Розв’яжемо задачу.
Дано: вектор а( 4;-5); вектор b(-1;7).
Знайти координати суми векторів і
модуль отриманого вектора.
Щоб знайти координати
суми, потрібно додати
координати векторів.
4-1=3
-5+7=2
Тобто координати суми (3;2)
Щоб знайти модуль цього вектора
потрібно взяти корінь
із суми квадратів координат.
9 та 4
тобто модуль цих векторів дорівнює
квадратному кореню із 13.
Розглянемо приклад з гри.
Маріо рухається вгору і вниз (стрибок).
Як це задати програмою?
Наприклад, якщо він буде рухатися з
одноковою швидкістю весь час,
тобто (1;3),
він просто буде летіти вгору як снаряд.
А для того, щоб він ішов
вниз, треба щось ще додати.
Це щось можна використати,
задати вектор, який буде відповідати за
умовну силу тяжіння.
Синій вектор відповідає за силу тяжіння.
Він тягне
нашого Маріо
вниз на одну клітинку.
Тобто це вектор (0;-1).
Якщо спочатку перший вектор відповідав
напряму і сили руху,
то далі сила тяжіння
його трішки вниз пішла.
Тепер знайдемо суму цих двох
векторів, чорного і синього.
Це буде вектор, який виходить з цієї точки
і йде до кінця синього вектора.
Додамо координати цих векторів
і отримаємо координати
другого вектора (1;2).
Далі кожного разу додаємо координати
вектора сили тяжіння (0;-1)
і він буде рухатися все менше і менше,
потім просто прямо,
а потім вниз іде.
І таким чином можна реалізувати
стрибок.
Наступний приклад.
У нас є книжка, яку тягнуть в різні боки
і зрозуміло, що вона не
буде рухатися на сто відсотків
в сторону хлопчика або ніндзя,
тому що вони обоє її тягнуть,
тобто ця книжка буде рухатися між ними.
Це також інший спосіб додавання векторів.
Якщо ми додамо ці два вектори,
які відповідають за напрямок і силу,
то ми отримаємо той шлях,
той вектор, який відповідатиме
з якою силою і в якому напрямку
буде рухатися ця книжка.
Це можна зробити більш легко
за правилом паралелограма.
Правило паралелограма
відрізняється від правила трикутника,
але насправді реалізовує те саме.
Як додавати вектори.
Наприклад,
який алгоритм правила паралелограма.
Якщо у нас з вами є два вектора,
то за правилом трикутника
ми їх так переносили,
що кінець одного
співпадав з початком іншого,
то за правилом паралелограма ми маємо їх
так сумістити,
щоб їх початки були однакові.
І потім рисуємо паралелограм.
І тоді, починаючи з
цієї точки, йдемо сюди.
Проводимо діагональ
(синій вектор — це сума векторів).
Насправді, це те саме,
що і правило трикутника
якщо ми цей вектор
перенесемо не в початок,
а в кінець,
то вийде правило трикутника.
Тобто це одне і те
саме, просто інший спосіб
і його інколи набагато
легше застосовувати,
ніж правило трикутника.
Тепер попрактикуємося в задачах
на знаходження суми векторів
за правилом паралелограма.
Ми вже розв’язували цю задачу і знаходили
суму векторів за правилом трикутника.
Тепер будемо знаходити за
правилом паралелограма.
Розглянемо приклад а).
Нарисуємо вектор а.
Вектор b ми рухаємо не в кінець вектора а,
а так, щоб їх початки сумістилися.
Далі, щоб знайти їх суму,
нам треба нарисувати паралелограм
вектор, який починається зі спільного
початку і йде в нарисовану точку
і буде їх сума a+b.
Так само зробимо, наприклад,
другий варіант.
Нарисували вектор а і вектор b так,
щоб їх початки сумістилися.
Нарисували паралелограм.
І з спільного початку в нову точку
буде вектор, який відповідає за їх суму.
Тепер розглянемо
рисунок.
Ми вже знаємо, що за правилом трикутника,
якщо ми нарисуємо подібним чином
a і b вектор, то їх сума
це буде червоний вектор,
який виходить з початку першого вектора
і до кінця другого вектора,
це у нас буде сума векторів.
А тепер перепозначимо вектори:
червоний - х,
а нижній - у.
Тоді як ми можемо написати новий
червоний вектор, чому він дорівнює?
Якщо ми знаємо, що Y і цей новий вектор
дорівнює х,
то як знайти червоний?
Наприклад, 2 - що треба
додати, щоб отримати 5?
Щоб знайти невідоме,
треба від 5 відняти 2.
Те саме з векторами. Якщо до цього вектора
щось треба додати, щоб отримати цей,
то цей вектор,
який невідомий, це буде
різниця векторів, тобто х-у.
І за цим
рисунком ми бачимо
правило як віднімати вектори.
Алгоритм віднімання векторів.
Для того, щоб відняти два вектора
a і b,
нам треба сумістити їх початки.
Паралельно перенести вектор b,
щоб їх початки співпадали.
Далі все залежить від того,
який вектор від якого ми віднімаємо.
Якщо a-b,
то рухаємося від кінця вектора b
в кінець вектора а.
Це буде різницею a і b.
Якщо b-a,
робимо спільними початки
то рухаємося від кінця а до кінця b.
Тобто із кінця а в кінець b
Це будуть два протилежно
направлені відрізки.
Рухаємось туди від чого віднімаємо.
Від кінця до кінця.
Розв’яжемо задачу на віднімання векторів.
Отже, у нас є паралелограм АВСD.
Потрібно побудувати різеицю векторів.
Різниця векторів ВА і ВС.
У нас вже є спільний початок.
Ми від ВА віднімаємо ВС,
тобто в сторону ВА буде йти наш вектор
з кінця того вектора,
який ми віднімаємо до
того, від якого віднімаємо.
Відповідь: вектор СА.
Інша задача.
Різниця векторів ВА і DA.
Нам треба зробити так, щоб у них
були спільні початки.
З’єднаємо вектори початками (червоні).
За умовою задачі, від ВА
віднімаємо DA,
отже рухаємося в кінець вектора ВА.
Із кінця одного вектора в кінець іншого.
Отриманий вектор дорівнює вектору BD.
Отже, BA-DA=BD.
Останній пункт робиться так само.
А що робиться з координатами?
Ми вже знаємо, якщо ми додаємо вектори,
то, щоб знайти координати суми,
треба додати координати.
А тепер у нас віднімання.
Так от, щоб знайти віднімання також
треба відняти відповідні координати.
Розв’яжемо задачу.
У нас є два вектори а і b
Потрібно знайти
координати та модуль різниці
Щоб знайти координати різниці,
треба від координат вектора а відняти
координати вектора b.
4 - (-1) = 5
-5 -7 = -12
Тобто координати
різниці буде вектор (5;-12).
Тепер як знайти модуль.
Використовуємо формулу для модулів.
Корінь квадратний
із суми квадратів координат.
Дивись на дошку.
Це буде √169, тобто 13.
Наступний приклад.
У нас є солдат і його розташування
задається вектором (2;3),
а розташування дракона — вектором (6;4).
Якщо ми хочемо нарисувати вектор,
який відповідатиме
напрямку руху цієї ракети
від нашого солдата до дракона,
щоб він поцілив,
то нам треба нарисувати червоний вектор.
Насправді, цей червоний вектор -
він іде з кінця першого в кінець другого.
І для того, щоб задати цей напрямок
від одного об’єкта до іншого,
зазвичай просто віднімають
вектори, їх розташування.
Віднімаємо (6;4) і (2;3). Отримали (4;1).
Попрактикуємося ще на одній задачі.
У нас є дві точки і треба знайти
модулі тих векторів, які задані.
Нарисуємо вектор ON і вектор OF.
Координати О ми не знаємо,
координати N і F знаємо.
Окремо знайти координати ON ми не можемо,
тому що не знаємо координати точки О.
Тому спочатку нарисуємо вектор ON-OF.
Ми віднімаємо від ON,
тобто від точки F рухаємося в напрямку
кінця першого вектора.
Вектор FN це і буде різниця ON-OF.
Вектор ON-OF.
Дивись на дошку.
Тобто, фактично,
в першій нашій частині нам треба
знайти модуль вектора FN.
Ми можемо це зробити, якщо знайдемо
координати цього вектора.
Координати вектора FN:
треба від кінця відняти початок,
тобто від координат точки N
відняти координати точки F.
І можемо знайти модуль:
корінь із суми квадратів
координат. √(1+36) = √37.
Це перша частина задачі.
Тепер подивимось на FO+ON.
Якщо ми хочемо нарисувати вектор,
давайте так само зробимо, тому що окремо
кожну координату ми не зможемо знайти,
а спочатку можна нарисувати що це вийде.
FO+ON.
Це правило трикутника.
Отже, можемо знайти одразу,
що сумою FO+ON буде вектор FN.
Тобто, фактично, у нас в умові сказано -
друга частина знайти модуль FN.
Але в першій частині ми робили те саме.
Отже, просто пишемо відповідь √37.
Отже, правильна відповідь: √37.
У нас в задачі є якісь точки.
Давайте їх нарисуємо.
Нам треба знайти суму векторів.
А1А2, а потім кожен наступний
починається із кінця першого.
Якщо ми подивимося
тільки на перші два вектори
А1А2+А2А3,
то це правило трикутника, тому що кінець
першого з початком другого сполучений.
Отже, буде вектор А1А3
за правилом трикутника.
Тобто сумою цих двох буде вже вектор А1А3.
Потім, якщо ми до цього
синього вектора додамо А3А4,
у нас знову правило трикутника. Кінець
першого з початком другого суміщений.
Отже буде вектор А1А4.
Додаємо ще точку А1А5
і т. д. до тих пір, поки
ми не дійдемо до кінця.
Тобто в кінці ми отримаємо вектор А1Аn.
Тобто сумою всіх цих векторів,
які виходять з кінця попереднього,
врешті-решт дорівнює вектору, який
виходить з початку першого вектора
до кінця останнього вектора А1An.
Дехто може запропонувати доведення,
яке включатиме метод
математичної індукції.
За вашим бажання можете
також цим методом користуватися.
Давайте розв’яжемо наступну задачу.
Нарисуємо ситуацію, де у нас
вектор, вектор і їх сума.
Розташуємо, щоб вийшло правило трикутника.
І їх сума a+b.
Що насправді в умові задачі написано?
Модуль вектора a+b
це відрізок
оце довжина
менший,
ніж сума
двох даних векторів (цих двох сторін).
Ми знаємо із курсу геометрії,
що сума двох сторін трикутника
завжди більша за третю сторону.
Тобто ця нерівність еквівалент
нерівності трикутника у векторній формі.
Зараз у мене запитання до вас.
Давайте розглянемо відповіді.
Якщо АВ=СВ,
то вони мають співпадати
і напрямок у них має бути однаковий.
Але ми бачимо, що вектори АВ і СВ
явно не колінеарні, вони не паралельні,
вони ще й перетинаються в точці В.
Можна сказати, що у них однакові довжини,
але те, що вектори однакові - не можна,
тому що у них різний напрям.
Якщо ми подивимось на останню
рівність АС-АВ,
то вектор АС мінус вектор АВ -
вони вже розташовані так, що
ми можемо вже записати відповідь.
Але ми пам’ятаємо, що напрямок у нас
до того вектора, від якого ми віднімаємо,
тобто буде в сторону АС.
Тобто вектор буде не СВ, а вектор ВС.
А от друга рівність
правильна, тому що АС+СВ
одразу за правилом трикутника -
це буде вектор АВ.
Отже, правильна відповідь друга.
Сьогодні ми з вами розбирали, як
додавати вектори і як віднімати вектори.
Щоб додати два вектори, треба
скористатися або правилом трикутника,
або правилом паралелограма.
Щоб відняти вектори,
треба сумістити їх початки і
нарисувати вектор, який виходить
з початку одного в кінець іншого.
А напрямок обрати так,
щоб він рухався в сторону
від того вектора, від якого ми віднімаємо.
Щоб краще зрозуміти тему, варто
відкрити підручник або збірник задач
і ров’язати задачі на ці теми.
Дякую, до побачення.